[Musique]
la bourse dans le rouge des banques qui
ferment et qui licencient à tour de bras
voilà ce qu'il s'est passé en 2008 et si
cette crise se reproduise et bientôt les
cracks se déclenche quand après une
longue période d'expansion monétaire
la rentabilité des entreprises devient
inférieur au coût des dettes qui ont été
accumulées et nous sommes exactement à
ce point aujourd'hui effectivement il ya
une grande différence
l'économie réelle l on le voit les
ralentis et tout le monde fait ce que
etc y compris les gouvernements tout le
monde s'active pour essayer de la sauver
et donc là c'est un petit peu anxiogène
mais les marchés financiers eux en tire
bénéfice parce que il ya de l'argent qui
arrive et ça c'est bon pour la bourse
en apparence tout semble se passer pour
le mieux côté bourse
tout va bien le cac40 n'a jamais été
aussi élevée depuis 2007 le nasdaq et le
dow jones deux indices américains n'ont
jamais été aussi haut
et pourtant il y a un vrai problème est
celui ci vient de la crise de 2008
c'est l'intervention très forte de
toutes les banques centrales qui se sont
engagés à tout faire pour soutenir la
croissance et donc elle injecte
énormément de liquidités pour relancer
la croissance
et même si ça marche pas très bien au
niveau de la croissance une bonne partie
de ses liquidités reviennent en bourse
arrive en bourse
et ça suffit à soutenir les cours le
problème c'est que normalement quand
l'économie va mieux on ralentit cette
injection de liquidités et il se trouve
que la pression était telle pour les
dirigeants politiques nous renseigne sur
les banques centrales que ces banques
centrales ont continué à le faire
vous ne comprenez pas pour faire simple
les banques centrales injectent de
l'argent en espérant doper la croissance
économique mais cela dope sur tous les
marchés financiers ce qui est très
dangereux puisque petit à petit le cours
de bourse se déconnecte de l'économie
réelle et c'est comme ça que se
produisent les krachs boursiers
aujourd'hui la bourse elle est dopée par
des taux bas et les liquidités qui sont
artificiellement agitée sur les marchés
évidemment l'essentiel c'est que
l'économie réelle reparte réellement
fortement et pour ça il faut évidemment
que le commerce mondial retrouve de la
confiance car pendant ce temps là la
croissance du pib mondial
c'est à dire l'augmentation de la valeur
de ce qui est produit dans le monde
diminue aujourd'hui le cycle économique
arrive à son terme et on voit que
l'économie ralentit fortement l'économie
mondiale est passée d'un peu plus de 4%
à moins de 3% de croissance
on a plusieurs pays qui sont en
difficulté l'argent qu'il ne va pas très
bien évidemment le venezuela mais les
pays asiatiques qu'un bien
la russie malgré les sanctions
finalement avec le prix du pétrole
ça se passe plutôt bien pour l'instant
il n'y a pas encore de signes forts et
imminent de le crise l'appui c'est la
raison pour laquelle finalement malgré
ce côté anxiogène les marchés façon
assez rationnel et tant qu'il n'ya pas
ainsi une réelle
ils vont continuer à acheter un krach
boursier se produit lorsque le marché se
réaligne sur l'économie réelle
c'est ce qu'on a vu en 1929 c'est ce
qu'on a vu en 2008 un triple sept 777
points perdus en une seule journée
jamais la bourse de new york n'avait
chuté comme cela le dow jones a perdu ce
lundi près de 7% de sa valeur
quant au nasdaq il a perdu un peu plus
de 9% c'est un verdict sans appel wall
street a cédé à la panique alors que
personne ne voit le début d'une solution
pour mettre fin à l'hémorragie qui
touche les banques américaines l'autre
alerte de cette crise
elle vient des banques car en ce moment
les taux d'intérêt sont devenus
tellement bas qu'ils sont passés en
négatif c'est à dire que les états ou
les grandes entreprises considérées
comme sûres
lorsqu'ils vont emprunter sur les
marchés vont se faire payer pour
contracter des prêts est mécaniquement
cela fait baisser les taux d'emprunt
chez les banques qui ne peuvent plus
faire assez de marge et ç'a un impact
sur l'économie réelle parce que si les
grandes entreprises elles peuvent
trouver de l'argent en bourse les toutes
les entreprises plus petites elles ont
toujours besoin des banques pour pour
investir et pour faire leur métier et
aujourd'hui les banques sont
ne sont pas en capacité pour des raisons
techniques de d'apporter tout l'argent
dont le marché a besoin
autre sujet d'inquiétude le contexte
géopolitique les relations
internationales se sont énormément
dégrader la coopération avait été une
force en 2008 pas sûr que ce soit encore
le cas aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui la mondialisation a explosé
les uns et les autres donc une véritable
confrontation entre les états unis et la
chine
les blocs se sont restructurées il n'y a
plus du tout dialogue
les institutions et les règles ont été
largement démantelé donc ce sera du
chacun pour soi
alors sommes nous condamnés à vivre
bientôt un nouveau krach boursier
ça le camp nul ne le sait mais il est
vrai que le compte à rebours du prochain
choc est en tout cas déjà engagé le pari
de donald trump
c'est d'essayer de faire en sorte que la
bulle tiennent jusqu'à l'élection
présidentielle américaine
aujourd'hui ça n'est pas certain du tout
mais le problème c'est en bourse qui lui
fit fils ait trouvé de timing quand il y
aura un crack
peut-être pas tout de suite
[Musique]
merci à vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
jusqu'au bout vous pouvez retrouver
toutes nos vidéos décrypteurs ici et
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner à notre
chaîne